yeah so like i guess
like going off that uh that same vein
um like you know we we tried to have
like a traditional wedding you know it
was that's true we tried we we tried to
traditionally but like yeah it's because
also but like also like we're like a
bunch of weebs so like
it was even though it was like [ __ ]
painful to have this wedding be delayed
for two years it actually i think came
out to be like a blessing in disguise
yeah because it really really gave me
and sydney the time to really like
yeah to really like add a lot of like
little things like that would just like
us you know
um and like i feel like that's the thing
that you know people hopefully really
remember that when they like think back
to our wedding um because we wanted to
have like some
anime references at about our wedding of
course of course we did um but we didn't
want to have to we didn't want like a
full-on [ __ ] cosplay you know winning
which we don't want like a full-on weeb
waiting yeah yeah ultramark can be
sebastian michaelis yeah
and so like we we tried we tried you
know we gave uh we gave everyone like a
postcard with like a drawing of either
like it was me and sydney in a wedding
dress in like the end of eva end screen
yeah uh or or it was like the famous oro
one and i can't remember which one you
guys got i got the ava one oh you got
the everyone i got the
i don't remember that
ava oh you guys got the lucky one
why is that lucky i don't know because i
was i had a bunch of people coming to me
to be like i you gave me the [ __ ] rmo
one yeah really dee got the oriemo one
he was so pissed off yeah yeah what the
[ __ ] yeah but like we tried to write a
nice little personal message to everyone
who attended our wedding and it's like
little touches like this i don't think
we would have been able to do one if we
didn't have enough time and two
if there was like too many people there
yeah
yours was nice sydney just insulted me
yeah yeah i was like what the [ __ ]
that's sydney much the same with
everyone what the [ __ ]
what did i do i turned up didn't i
actually
but like another thing is we wanted to
like try to integrate like the places
we'd been to and the cultures we were we
lived in as much as possible so we had
like a
uh we had a custom-made mussoo box made
which if you don't know what that is
it's uh one of those sake boxes yeah
right so we had like a custom crest that
we
we made which was like a combination of
like both of our families and then we
gave everyone mastery boxes which you
normally drink sake out of yeah um but
so i was excited yeah yeah yeah so i was
like i was like telling everyone at the
table being like yeah so there's this
thing called like
that you use these masu boxes for we
like you pour it so much that it
overflows into the box and everyone was
like oh cool
and then
and then like if if you know me in
sydney you know that we are not sake
drinkers right yeah but like i don't
know why but there is a drink within our
group
which which we are like really famous
for drinking uh because every time we go
to like a party someone brings like
crates and crates of this stuff and so i
announce in my speech that we're not
going to be toasting with champagne but
we're going to be toasting with soju
and i'd heard from like several people
that joey was just joey's face was just
like i can't i how dare i was like i
i i've never experienced racism at a
wedding
but i felt like my culture was extremely
appropriate
oh my really
the [ __ ] sake i didn't even like
soldiers i did it for you
surprise the cultural appropriation yeah
i had several people being like dude bro
joey is pissed when you said that okay
pissed is like a strong no no i know i
know yeah like i was i was like yeah
[ __ ] whatever i was too much on like
a happy hive to give a [ __ ] it was like
the next day where i thought about it i
was like those [ __ ]
how dare you i'm gonna take this muscle
box home just because yeah god damn it
sake just tastes like [ __ ] food vodka
i don't know i mean like you guys just
haven't had the good [ __ ] i did i did
the 100 tasting sake thing it did all of
them happen to taste like [ __ ] yeah
you don't have the power for it
a powder one like a [ __ ] wood chip
not japanese enough i think so exactly
like fire shield yeah sake oh i used to
not like sake like i used to think it
was like paint thinner maybe maybe when
i get older maybe yeah
maybe yeah
maybe i've lived in japan for long
enough yeah i like i think like the next
thing i remember uh was actually like
the cake cutting so oh yeah yeah i don't
know what you guys remember but like i'm
trying to like think back to all like
the big [ __ ] things that i remember
about the wedding and
so so obviously it's traditional for a
wedding that you have like a cake
cutting with the bride and groom and
everyone like gathers around and like
take pictures and everything like that
and uh and i remember like sydney
like sydney cuts the cake and then honor
like her second slice she's like
completely like [ __ ] up and just goes
like diagonal
and
burst out laughing saying cindy what the
[ __ ] is that but then like she she she
like full-on just like grabs the slice
with her hand like shoves it in my face
and i'm like i'm like i'm like eating it
and then she like she like has a bite
for herself
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and obviously like everyone's laughing
everyone's applauding and everything and
then
i turn over to maelyn and i see melin's
mouth moving and she says
and i'm just like what and i think you
know i think you know oh she must be
saying oh your size is so cute or
something congratulations i hear i i go
closer to be like melanie what'd you say
and she goes lick it lick her
[Laughter]
what the [ __ ] you're [ __ ] freaked
and i'm like what the [ __ ]
but i'm like
okay i'm [ __ ] i'll do it for you melin
i'll do it for you
oh she was just like
weird
so you just did like a bucharan
[Music]
yeah yeah she was cakes with makeup
cake basically in multiple
i've heard like some funny stories about
other people that uh
other things that have happened around
the wedding that i wasn't involved in
obviously everyone was drunk uh i think
one of the people who got drunk the
fastest actually was karen did you guys
see karen at all demon dice yeah i
didn't i i was the one that noticed that
she was like slouched on the couch like
just just forward slouched like this
yeah and i i walked up to her because no
one was there and i was like carry you
okay and then she just turns to me she's
like i [ __ ] up man
i [ __ ] up man i was like what happened
like like like what what did you get in
a fight or something like what happened
she's like no i thought i had
four
double shots of whiskey before the food
and i was like
why did you do that
just good vibes it was like okay because
i guess she was just having a really
good time yeah i showed it out my my
bedroom was on like the third floor no
elevator i [ __ ] showed with the [ __ ]
every time i had to go get some from my
room i came back down like fully shut
[ __ ] walking those stairs [ __ ] dude yeah
yeah this is my sluggish job like
[ __ ] my entire life
yeah so so i you know so i was kind of
comforting her getting her water and
[ __ ] and then sydney and uh and a bunch
of other girls came to be like all right
you know what you can just like go crash
in sydney's room yeah so that was okay
yeah the other one that was hilarious
was jan
yeah
because he wasn't [ __ ] there
like it was like i was talking i was
literally talking to him it was it was
me and marky and jan and we were just
chatting and it was like 30 minutes
before the dinner yeah all right and
then jan was like
dude
i'm gonna get a nap and i'm like jan the
the dinner's in like literally 30
minutes like we're about to go in to sit
down and he's like oh no no don't worry
i'll be back i'll be back bro don't
worry
and we never saw him again
man went for cigarettes and never came
back like it was like the dad going for
milk and cigarettes i was just like yeah
i'll be back and then it was like 10 p.m
when i noticed like i i came out of my
drunken stupor and i was like
yeah
has anyone seen jan yeah i called him i
was like what the [ __ ] are you because
he also yeah but right when he's about
to leave he i was like where are you
going he said i'm gonna go to sleep and
like dude dinner right yeah like come
it's right now yeah yeah and he was just
like no no no i'll be back i'm like
you're not gonna [ __ ] be back i know
you're not you're not gonna be back
eat the [ __ ] i was like at least eat the
dinner and then go they paid for the
food eat the food and then leave yeah
and that was literally the last time i
saw him until now and like i i texted
him i think like on the day i was about
to fly out like to la because i just
remembered i was like yeah yeah that was
literally the last time i saw and talked
to jan so i texted him being like are
you alive that is that is one question
i've asked jan more than any other
person i know in my life he just
disappears yeah he just disappears and
you just don't know where he is so he's
like are you all alive
one friend yeah and he was like yeah bro
yeah you were telling me about how you
saw jan in like the most jan place
before the before the wedding started
right so it was before the wedding
started and uh and it was connor myself
and i forgot who else someone else i was
mood on i think yeah uh and we were just
like let's just go get like uh because
you know dinner wasn't until like 4 p.m
right and we had gathered at like midday
so like well [ __ ] i'm gonna be starving
throughout this reception right so i was
just like yeah let's just there's a cafe
around the corner let's just go there
and i was walking there and i walked and
we walked past this this alleyway yeah
right
and
i literally did a double take i was like
like that because
jan is standing there
full suit sunglasses with a cigarette in
his hand just talking to a homeless dude
and i knew and he was like and it was
like the most scruffy homeless dude he's
wearing like this red bathroom with like
this cigarette in his hand i don't know
if he was homeless you just dressed like
uh [ __ ] um what's uh daniel radcliffe
in the guns of kimberly
without the guns
like today you mean the one where he's
like yeah yeah yeah literally that
literally that outfit yeah like one for
once like without the hands yeah it's
just like no shoes bathrobe just with a
little nappy hair with a cigarette in
his hand and jan's just like properly
dressed up in sunglasses with a
cigarette and i'm just like jan and he
looks over and he's like bro help me
i'm like what do you mean he'd help you
and he's like and because he's like he's
like oh sorry my friend's here and then
he walks over to me and i'm like what do
you know that guy and he's like no
and i'm like why were you there and he's
like because he asked for a cigarette
and i saw i just gave him a cigarette
and then he just started talking to me
and i couldn't leave and i'm like what
do you mean you can you could very
easily leave you could just be like
sorry i have somewhere to go but because
of course jan's just too [ __ ] nice
and nice he just tries to sweet talk
everywhere he's like he's like speech
100 yeah every time right so he's just
like yeah he's like oh thanks for saving
me bro and i'm like yeah i literally did
nothing i just walked past that you were
talking to a dude in a bathroom it's the
most jan thing i've ever seen in my life
oh my god yeah like another thing that
[ __ ] cracked me up as well was like
because moon on flew in from estonia
just to basically come to come to this
wedding yeah i felt so bad we were like
this was like before like the world like
the ceremony we're all getting ready in
like the boys powder room and then mudon
comes in and then connor's like mood on
i got something for you
into his bag and brings out the hard
disk
of the previous trash chase episodes
that we had just filmed in england
yeah so i i i didn't just spring this on
here i wasn't like that so we recorded
the trenches episode ones in the uk
right but obviously in the uk and the us
like these episodes are normally about
400 gigabytes total yeah and like we've
been blessed by japanese there's just no
internet speeds that can do it so it was
either we ship it to him uh to like in
estonia which would probably it would
actually be faster than f trying to find
somewhere to upload yeah yeah yeah so he
was coming to the wedding i messaged him
like hey uh i know this is like kind of
like weird but can i just give you the
ssd of the episodes in person and he was
like yeah sure
but then obviously he was kind of
playing it up in first and he was like
wow really making me work today
i was like come on man
i'm just like thank you for coming all
the way to england here's some work
he specifically said i'm gonna bill you
for this hour
all right okay
whatever hey but it all turned out okay
yeah yeah you guys got the episode on
time and that's because mulan got the
work at my wedding
yeah and like like to build on like the
karen story because you saw like the
girls like
you go you saw like the girls like dr
like
carrying her off to her yeah yeah yeah
um so cindy told me what happened after
they started carrying her off so i told
you the story about my mum at like
my cousin's previous wedding right well
like i've never i never have never seen
my drum my mom drunk before but like i
saw like a sleeping dragon like awaken
at my cousin's wedding
i saw that sleeping dragon awaken even
harder this time right
because apparently what happened was
sydney was like trying to like help
karen up to her room she feels a tap on
the shoulder
turns around it's my mom
and she has a beer in hand and she says
she's like trying to be polite being
like oh mom are you doing okay i'm
trying to i'm trying to get my friend up
to her room's like camera's like yeah i
constantly on city shoulder my mom's
like my mom's like watch this
and she downs the bottle of beer
like she doesn't even like say do you
want me to down this yeah this time she
just goes watch this and she goes she
downs it walks away yeah i said he's
like mommy i'm kind of busy right now
and [ __ ] and around my mom looks like
karen and my mom looks back in sydney
and she goes i'll be back wait here and
apparently she goes she tries to go back
to do it again i said he's like mom i
really need to take my friend up to like
my room right now
yeah my god my mom didn't even make it
to the end of the night was popping off
dude yeah yeah she was popping off you
were popping off on the [ __ ] dance
floor holy [ __ ] [ __ ] joe i was with d
and you know and he can dance his ass
off yeah and i heard the calgary summer
opening and i was like i have to pop
there's people that played i didn't know
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah because like the dance
floor was kind of weird because it was
like there was either no one there or
everyone was there yeah there was no
in-between so it was during the time
where it was like me dean like a couple
of other people and we just you know
there's like a couple of tracks playing
and then and then the kaguya summer
theme starts and we're just like
well we've gotta dance to this all right
like we're gonna pop off to this one
yeah yeah yeah and so i just stopped
popping off because i was stupidly drunk
not realizing someone is behind me
filming this entire ordeal right yeah
and so when i received the video i was
like
wow i'm [ __ ] right now
i'm so [ __ ] because i never dance yeah
because i can't dance for [ __ ] yeah i
was i was dancing like my life was
[ __ ] depending on it yeah and then
you went again when uh dev manoj uta
started playing again
playing i was like all right all right
ty is coming off today
[Music]
yeah because i remember we went in waves
because everyone went on the dance floor
and then everyone was like let's get a
drink and then everyone immediately went
to the bar and it was just it just kept
coming in waves but i remember like the
the time when everyone started to pop
off was when [ __ ] september played
[Music]
and that's and that's when that's when
the video like me and joey [ __ ]
hugging yeah um came about but like i
remember before that i remember i like
gave connor that corner the hug as well
because
because it was like [ __ ] september
and everyone was so hyped and that was
that was like i think like the hyper
song i don't know why it was september
because i like because i thought it was
just like it's happening it's a happy
song and also like every time we used to
go to karaoke together yeah that song
was always the best oh yeah yeah yeah so
that's where i thought it was yeah yeah
yeah yeah but like i would say like if
okay so one of i think one of the best
decisions i made with my wedding if you
are
planning advice right yeah if here's
here's some wedding advice um if you're
ever planning uh if you're planning a
future wedding or something so like even
though there was only 62 people at my
wedding which is a fairly small wedding
in my eyes smaller yeah yeah smaller
wedding like wedding fomo is a [ __ ]
thing because
i wanted to be with everyone at all
times i wanted to see what was [ __ ]
popping off what people were talking
about i just wanted to see what's going
on because like because there's only one
of me and because there's like only so
much so many hours in this one [ __ ]
day you can only be at one place at a
time and it's like i had so many regrets
um because we also like really really
[ __ ] busy with the photographers
getting like our own wedding photos or
something like one thing i big one
probably my biggest figure of the
wedding is that i didn't see everyone's
reaction to the postcards and all the
messages and stuff because we were like
should have all filmed your reaction so
i can react to it later yeah
so see because we were outside taking
wedding photography uh when you guys
were in so like
one of the best decisions i made is that
i had we had like a gopro there uh
because of course we did i learned from
trash tastes right i learned from trash
taste of course and i was just i went to
like everyone and i was like film
whatever you want just just just film
whatever you want
um and
like i've seen the footage and i'm just
like it's it gives you like such an on
the ground experience to what everyone
was doing and like we haven't we had
videographers there and so i'm very very
excited to see what they captured on
their ends but i think it's just like it
was like it was a totally different view
when you just had people filming their
own povs on gopros right um because like
you got to see like the progression
everyone was like so well spoken so
happy at the beginning of the wedding
and then you go to like the end footage
yeah
and yeah it was like it was like it was
like one of the best decisions i think
regarding my wedding because i got to
see so much my wedding that i wouldn't
have got to see
if uh
if if i did if i didn't have a gopro
there so yeah trash tastes special
unfortunately you guys are never going
to see that uh but uh it does it does
exist on my hard drive oh yeah yeah but
yeah like i said fantastic day you know
i know it's a cliche to say like you
know your wedding's like the happiest
day of your life but it was it wasn't
three yeah
like no one's that jaded where they're
like yeah my wedding was all right yeah
of course i mean i live it up yeah i
mean like
because like before the wedding i was
just like you know maybe it'll be the
happiest day of my life you know it's i
didn't really think about it too much
looking back it was genuinely the
happiest day of my life so far so i'm
glad i'm glad i got i'm glad you guys
got to share that you know yeah it's
[ __ ] awesome yeah i think that's the
best thing about having a wedding to me
like we had a lot of mates there and it
was just having your mates around to
experience like the happiest moment of
your life is something that i cannot put
into words it's just it's it's it's so
[ __ ] special yeah absolutely and joey
wore trainers
oh yeah oh yeah we're gonna talk about
that
joey got the besties on i do okay so
you know because the wedding was not
done in london it was done just outside
of london right yeah so we were in
london you know for about a week i was
hanging out with a bunch of people what
not and i i had forgotten because
because originally i was supposed to get
a suit from the suit rental place that
god had organized yeah but because right
now in the uk and just i guess
everywhere in the world it's like
wedding craze right now because you know
we're approaching the end of the
pandemic um
they were all booked up right so gant
messaged me like a few days before i was
about to fly out to uk being like hey so
sorry but i wasn't able to get your suit
rental yeah so you're gonna have to
bring your own suit yeah and i was like
okay
i only have a jojo suit i mean that's
fine that's sort of which was okay so i
was like whatever you know i'll just get
that dry clean you know where whatever
but then when i got to london and i was
sorting out my luggage i was like [ __ ] i
forgot to
bring my suit shoes yeah right and so in
the back of my head i was like well i'm
in london for like an entire week i'll
just like pop over to a shoe store and
buy some nice shoes right yeah
uh i got a little bit ham in london
i was like drinking every day in london
right because of course you do yep you
know meeting up catching up with a bunch
of people so
the morning of the wedding yeah as i was
taking my suit out i realized i don't
have suit shoes
and the only pair of shoes i had were
the vessies that i was wearing
so i rocked up to the wedding
in full suit you know tai pin belt
everything yeah and a pair of vessies
yeah and uh everyone at the wedding was
giving me [ __ ] they were like they
literally they were literally doing the
water
you know fully deserved mind you but um
but you know what at the end of the day
i won because when i got onto that
[ __ ] dance floor dude i was fully
prepared
i was fully prepared with my everyone
like had taken their shoes off to dance
i was like step aside i got the footwear
for you yeah yeah yeah yeah so that was
uh don't do that
bring bring
bring proper sushi i had one job to buy
sutures and i did not fulfill it making
a making a statement there making a
statement exactly i was making a
statement